slightly autistic ladies and gentlemen
this is the one and only Hans Kim
[Applause]
this is
on scam
what's up
I love it here in Austin but I'm not a
big fan of tech Bros
I think people in the 20s who made
washing machines and refrigerators were
like yeah I work in Tech
had a little lanyard
I uh I saw a woman try to break up a
fight by yelling out stop fighting
you're grown men
I wonder what she yells out when she
sees teenagers fighting
although this is totally appropriate for
your maturity level
um yeah love uh love it here in Texas
[Music]
I um
I think it's uh great to uh you know
finally
be doing another minute here on kill
Tony uh
I did one yesterday please be easy on me
um you know the Mexican cartel recently
killed two Americans and they apologized
for it which is great you know my
American passport doesn't get me health
care but if I go to Mexico I get treated
like a panda bear
like all right thank you
oh oh
listen to the murmurs happening in this
audience they know they're seeing
something special right now Hans Kim has
a new hot white girlfriend and she has
been literally [__] his brains out
and we got to watch you really hit your
[__] limit this week huh you can
write a minute a week and it turns out
you can write a minute 20 seconds a week
we found out we did a taping yesterday
which we very rarely do hard to write
two minutes in one week you've proven
that here
if we anyone question it let there be
known you seemed preoccupied tonight is
there any reason for that at all
um not really I'm sober I didn't do
cocaine today
um I have a mission I think I see the
problem
maybe this is what's happening we watch
you go from you know barely having money
for food to literally we find found out
last night you've been doing cocaine on
a regular basis this is what I love
about this show is that no one knew Hans
you know two and a half years ago and
here we are two years later we followed
What It's Like for somebody to [__]
make it and now we're starting to see
your rock and roll down fall it's like
that's the set they're gonna show when
they're like and then the problem began
and you're up here talking about [__]
Mexican cartels and panda bears or
whatever the [__] he said
how do you feel Hans what else is going
on in life anything you feel good uh I
uh crashed my drone into the side of a
parking garage recently wow Asian
problems ladies oh my goodness into the
side of a what was it parking garage
okay did you break it I damaged it and I
sent it in for repairs
um I you don't just do that yourself
[Laughter]
isn't that like part of what you guys do
don't you make the Drone in the first
place
I'm more of the laundry type of Asian
there you go
[Applause]
there you go I know I know somebody who
just wrote another five seconds
yesterday next week just got a little
bit easier it's a shame you didn't have
that up your sleeve which you could do
because you specialize in laundry
um so I love it Hans you got the uh you
got the show started as always you've
shown people exactly how hard it is to
do a new minute uh and like I said back
to back nights that's not easy at all
you're out here [__] living the dream
how do you feel I feel great yeah I'm
gonna try to you know make you proud
next next week Tony
[Laughter]
this is my son
my Daniel's son
one more time for him everybody not an
easy gig at all not an easy gig a new
minute every week to the internet is